could you ever see a point in time where
let's say
you're not on griselda anymore obviously
your family obviously you're still going
to represent that [ __ ] but like
contractually
like is that is that something that like
you could see eventually happening or is
it kind of just like hey look this is
how i got here
we riding this [ __ ] to the wheels
falloff type situation i'm benny the
butcher gonna always be griselda a
hundred percent
i'm gonna always be grazelda because
it's like
even just even if i'm at a different
label whatever i'm just gonna always be
griselda you know i'm saying it's like
we is griselda what we built and what we
put together or it's not like
[ __ ] ain't gonna do what was she gonna
do two or three or four like [ __ ] like
that is you can always expect that like
if anybody go anywhere it ain't like oh
we ain't working together it's still the
formula 100 and like i feel like you
guys are like um
very much like
i don't know pick a [ __ ] nba dynasty
you know
we like west side gun is phil jackson
you know what i'm saying west side guns
phil jackson kobe and kobe and shaq is
you and conway it's um you know what i'm
saying it's like
it's like it's it's always the best with
y'all
always always that's why
you're going you always going to have a
con that that benny conway album
people don't know but people who've been
listening to me i built my [ __ ] up off
the benny the butcher conway songs when
i put my first brick out in 2016 when
they had they when they was doing the
underground run he was on my [ __ ] three
times
you know what i'm saying so i'll be on
like he call it he come get me for those
type of records like
always that tyson versus ali always i
feed off of [ __ ] like that then you got
gun on the album
um shout out to gun
i don't know if what i heard is even
going to make the project or not but
it's guns there's a record on their guns
talking some [ __ ] he's he's on some dj
khaled
[ __ ] ric flair ass
he talking some [ __ ] man paulie heyman
type [ __ ] that's how i love buzz man
buzz i love butt huh
yeah yeah that's what he do man